على الاقل اتحاد الافريقي عضويه نيامي في
كل انشطته واكد انه يدرس قرار ايكواس
تحضير قوات لنشرها في النيجر
ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما مدى تاثير
قرار الاتحاد الافريقي بتعليق عضويه
النيجر على مسار الازمه ما مواقف القوى
الدوليه والاقليميه من قرار الاتحاد
الافريقي وما افاق الخروج من المازق
السياسي في النيجر
[موسيقى]
الاتحاد الافريقي
وبعدما حصل في غينيا في السودان ومالي
وبوركينا فاسو الان اتى دور النيجر
الاتحاد الافريقي يحاول ان يشدد على اهميه
الابتعاد عن النزاع ما من احد يود ان يرى
هذا القتال وكيف
للشعب في النيجر ان يستفيد من اي تدخل
عسكري الشعب لا يود ذلك كلنا نعلم ان
الايكواس وما تحاول ان تقوم به وانها
تعاقبنا عقابا شديدا لا يمكن لهذه المنظمه
ان تفعل هذا الموضوع يدعون انهم يحمون
الشعب ولكن هذا خطا يجب العمل على الحل
الدبلوماسي بالنسبه الى مساله
ولذلك يتعين علينا ان نتواصل مع
عسكريين للتوصل الى الحلول
في البدايه هي تؤشر الى ان الاطراف
المختلفه تتفاوض
وتتباحث وتتشاور بدات المفاوضات بتحديد
مثلا المهله الانتقاليه ثلاث سنوات كلا
سته اشهر ما هي المهله التي انتم بحاجه
اليها لتنظيم انتخابات بعد ذلك تحركت
المهله الى سنه او اكثر هذه مفاوضات اذا
هناك اوراق مطروحه على طاوله المفاوضات
الان يقطعون عنا الكهرباء في لونا الحدود
لا تصل البضائع كذلك الادويه والشعب يعاني
بارسال يجب ان لا ننسى ان موقف الاتحاد
الافريقي لم يكن موحدا سوف يؤدي ذلك الى
تبعات مختلفه والى تدخل خارجي من الولايات
المتحده ومن اوروبا ومن روسيا
[موسيقى]
حين تعرضنا للارهاب لم يتدخلوا لم تتدخل
الان من اجلي ابقاء الرئيس السابق تريد
الاقواس التدخل العسكريا هذا فعلا امر غير
شرعي اذا ما وصل الامر الى الحل العسكري
الشعب النيجر لا يود ان يقاتل فتنعرف انهم
يهددون وهذا مجرد تهديد يقولون انهم سوف
يتدخلونه عسكريا نحن مستعدون ونحن في
انتظارهم النيجر هو اصلان
يضم شعبا مقاتلا نحن الشعب هو الذي سوف
يقاتل ضد الاكوا